>> That's good, David. Note that David started on the top left corner, this is
a random selection. He could have started at any other corner, for example,
this one or that one. And found the same answer and that is because we have
simplified these constraints. But now that we know that this line is a fold,
by the definition of fold, we know that two surfaces must be meeting at this
line. It follows then, that this must be a surface and this must be a surface.
Similarly, because we know this is a fold and by definition of a fold,
two surfaces must be meeting here. Follows this is a surface,
this is a surface and so on. And now we have identified that this one surface,
this is another surface, this is a third surface. In this way, the visual system
used knows the different kinds of junctions in the world of triangular objects,
and it constrains at each of these junctions to figure out which of
these lines made surfaces. Instead of thinking of this as one single surface,
the visual system identified this as being composed of three different surfaces.
And now we can recognize that this might be a cube.